[Music]
and I wanted to show you a game I played
against Anatoly Karpov d6c for ePHI d
takes e5 d takes e5 Queen takes d8 King
takes d8 move like Knight c3 c6 is a
position I or pardon me maybe just to be
more most precise Bishop e6 b 3 9 d 7 9
f3 f6 Bishop b2 c6 is the type of
endgame I would just embrace as black I
just thought that not only didn't I have
a disadvantage I actually liked blacks
position even though I've lost this
ability to castle because once again I
felt that my king is going to be super
safe super solid on the c7 square
windows installed well thank you very
much for the new and updates ok so in
nineteen ye know I should remember the
day I think it was 1990 probably 1990 I
had played in a tournament in Sweden
Hani Hani McGee Orhan Inge in Sweden and
it was very very nice top category
tournament and the favorite in the field
was Anatoly Karpov so essentially this
game I was white decided first I opened
up with 1 C 2 C 4 he answered e5 I
answered G 3 so this is a very popular
way for black to meet the English with E
5 and after G 3 black has to decide
whether he wants to play Knight f6 and D
five or whether he wants to play a
proper English
and so forth and so on I have a lot of
experience was with white Anatoly played
d7 d6 which was a very strange decision
by Anatoly almost always when he gets in
this position as black on move - he is
always played either Knight f6 or knight
c6
so it was like d7 d6 kind of like
through between threw me off like what
it was that he was aspiring for with
black anyway I took up the challenge and
I played d4 and he really shocked me we
got this position G 7 g 6 and we get the
ending that I've been talking about pawn
takes pawn takes Queen takes King takes
now in this specific position that's not
that this moved g7 g6 is a waste of
tempo or anything like that yes Amen
no not not that that this position is
that there's a couple of differences
from earlier that earlier endgame that
we have the inclusion of these two moves
g2 g3 and g7 g6 and how the inclusion of
the move g2 g3 is actually in whites
paper remember in that ending that I was
talking about how the pawn on c4 kind of
limits the bishop on f1 that that's not
a really on a good diagonal well now
that I've included the move g2 g3
exactly so exactly so so in an in a
certain small way I've gained what we
might call a tempo also in this exact
position it's not let the move g7 g6 is
necessarily bad only that probably black
had a much more useful move maybe c7 c6
or Bishop e6 then the move g6 so just a
small nuance variation starts to change
the whole assessment of the whole
position now in this position I played
Knight c3 and here Anatoli display just
asking the class what do you think would
be a good move for black in this exact
position just toss out some live
Bishop e6 is a good move another one
possibly Bishop to b4 an excellent
decision Bishop to b4 to go here okay
true I mean okay but that would trade
bishops so we've heard Bishop e6 a very
very decent move Bishop before very very
decent move what do you think about the
move c7 c6 doesn't that move fit in the
position I mean after all you're ready
to bring your king to c7 well you mean
that this square well but you're going
to be able to defend it with either the
bit the pawn or the bishop
oh you're suggesting that the move yes
yes well the move c7 c6 by its nature
does weaken both the b6 and d6 squares
however the idea the deeper idea is
simply to give the King on d8 sanctuary
a square a place that it can hide well
let's go back for a moment and in this
position again we could see for example
Bishop to b4 this would it be a kind of
an interesting move if I were black
you'd you'd have to be
worried about Bishop g5 check f6 castles
check yeah but check let us say Knight
to d7 just as a to choose a move and
you'd have to calculate this variation
Knight d5 so you could capture the
bishop if you will but of course black
army white would recapture that Bishop
and maybe you're not happy about your
pawn structure and by the way pay
attention besides this this also Knight
takes f6 so Bishop b4 well it's a decent
move you have to be fraught with dangers
now on the other hand let's just take a
look at Bishop e6 for a second suppose
Bishop e6 a very reasonable move and
let's suppose b2 b3 and again at some
point you're going to have to recognize
that one day you're gonna want to play
c6 okay all very good all very very
reasonable in the game Anatoli played c7
c6 and the remarkable thing about this
move is that after this move
he's almost lost he's almost lost well
let's say his position is so bad
it's almost beyond repair yeah I'm gonna
show it to you you bet like woah how is
that possible yes
exactly yes it would make all the
difference in the world indeed and we'll
get to exactly that it will all be very
obvious exactly what you're saying well
that's the interesting part is exactly
here if you were to assign a numerical
position a numerical evaluation I would
say that the computers are going to
assess it it may be a half upon two
nine-tenths of upon but as you'll see
I'm going to assign it almost a three a
four it's really huge and let's see what
happened okay so the first point is we
fully understand the concept of the c7
c6 e c7 c6 move as you want to make a a
hole for your king but here's the
problem and suddenly it becomes
extremely obvious F 2 F 4 well what's
the concept here well beside the fact
I'm attacking the pawn on e5 I'm really
welcoming
he takes F Bishop takes f4 when your
king will not find sanctuary on the c7
square I'm going to Castle with a check
and your king is in fact on an open
highway with nowhere to go there you go
there you go all I need to do is check
them so Anatoli
he played Bishop e6 okay so he's
attacking my pawn on c4 perfectly
logical
I played Knight f3 and again I'm
welcoming Hey
capture on f4 so that I could capture on
f4 and if he were to capture on c4 I
would castle with check gamba ting upon
and going after his king yes sorry it's
my turn so in this position if I were to
capture the pawn right away then after
Bishop takes I haven't managed to really
open up the position for my pieces so he
played after Knight f3 he captured on c4
so already it's pretty obvious that
after I capture with a knight on e5 and
he goes back with his Bishop to e6 I
have an advantage how big it is I don't
know but I have a much stronger move
then Knight takes e5 and here is that
move Bishop h3 well my idea is I want to
capture this pawn on e5 attacking his
pawn on c4 his Bishop his bishop on c4
and his pot on f7 and he won't be able
to play the move Bishop e6 now let's
just go back for a moment back back back
back back to this position let it open
me to this position let's imagine that
black had played the move Bishop e6
Michaels mode and let's imagine that I
had played the move b3 and he had played
the move Knight d7 now the point is
after I played the move Bishop g2 then
played the move c76 in other words let
white first develop his Bishop to g2
provoking the move c7 c6 in the game
what
happen was that I play Bishop h3 I
didn't play my Bishop wasn't on g2 and
now I'm threatening Knight takes e5
winning by the way did you look up the
numerical score okay no worries I don't
know some people have a chess engine on
their phone and it would be kind of
curious
I haven't played through this game in
numerous years so I don't even know what
the modern chess engines would think
only at this moment I was very very
happy with my position I was again I was
very hopeful that he would take which is
very helpful to me I would play Bishop
takes I'm getting all my pieces
developed and his King is still stuck in
the center of the board he played after
a great deal of thinking f7 f5 now here
I was actually quite proud of myself and
I encourage you all to do this from time
to time to really to understand chess to
get to the heart of the position I very
much believe in this is that you should
ask your pieces what they are doing
ask your pieces what they are doing know
what their job is what they think their
job is so for example in this position I
think everybody would play Knight takes
e5 capturing upon with a tempo which is
very very nice awesome in fact the
bishop would come back I think everybody
would play a move for example like E to
e for and then for example after I don't
know let's just pick a move for a moment
let's say Knight d7 I think everybody
would be very very satisfied with
White's position that it's just a good
position for white that you could take
on d7 maybe play e5
yeah but it's kind of blocked it's kind
of blocked its blocked up exactly so
we're gonna go back a moment to this
position and I really liked the great
advice of Michael tall when you see a
good move stop think maybe there's a
better move
so Knight takes e5 is an obviously good
move but following Michael calls advice
let's stop and let's think and let's
talk to our pieces for a moment and in
this moment I'm talking to my pieces
everybody's happy everybody's got a job
and they're anxious to get on with it I
mean a move like e to e for has to be
considered that's a very nice move
trying to open up the position and blast
things open and then my bishop on c1
started crying out exactly my bishop was
saying hey man what's my motivation
what's my role in this game what am I
supposed to do look at Bishop and I said
you're right look at that beautiful long
diagonal and at the end of that diagonal
this is this rainbow there's this rook
on h8 now my bishop were on that long
diagonal okay but that would block the
diagonal and how am I supposed to put
the bishop on the day
if I capture with the pond then my
bishop it can't get really good nicely
on that long diagonal precisely how
about b-two b-three that does very very
nicely this is our new mainline
excellent and now by the way where is
the bishop going now imagine the bishop
were to move for argument's sake to the
square e six
well after Bishop e6 remember last time
I played Knight takes e5 Bishop e6 now
that the bishops on e6 maybe I can go
and I can attack the bishop with Knight
to g5 the king in the rook oh that would
be very nice thank you
former world champion you give meat the
rook and what about for example King to
e7 well that would be a disaster that's
just an absolute disaster for a black
thanks to Bishop a3 check and if the
King moved to d7 well this is really you
know like horrible horrible and how
about King to d7 right away well again
King to d7 right away this is also
horrible horrible after for black after
Bishop b2 it's very clear that white has
mobilized his army most excellently and
his next move is going to be castles
with gain the tempo that whole diagonal
is is full disaster
right and let's say the bishop
so in that case well let's say the
bishop were to drop back to f7 and not
to e6 well in this case I would capture
with the tempo and I'd have that exact
same position that we had a moment ago
except my pawn wouldn't be on b2 it's on
B 3 and so I could put my Bishop on b2
and gain a very very important tempo so
here Anatoli after the move b3 he played
the only move he could Bishop b4 new
main line
I played Bishop b2 and he played Bishop
d5 I'd love to I'd love to
I'd love to capture that Bishop and then
capture that pawn and capture the rook
except one problem it's illegal the
bishop would take my king so I can't
take the bishop
right so here I think of exactly I think
a lot of people would be very very moded
motivated in this position to play
castles because let's just imagine that
well exactly and bring my rook
first of all with castles I get out of
the pen and secondly I bring my rook to
the open D file and pin his bishop the
problem with this line of reasoning is
that after Bishop takes Bishop takes
Knight here let's suppose Knight takes
e5 and then after rook f8 I like White's
position but it's not completely clear
is it I mean black has the squares d5
and E for like black might bring his
Knight to e4 and right now it's hard to
say how big in advantages yes it is
fortunately it's an append for the
moment but then my rook will be hanging
exactly so I have to keep an eye on that
so here pardon me while anatoliy was
thinking about his move bishop d5 i
anticipated he would play that move and
I had already anticipated my response to
Bishop d5 and as I was thinking about it
I was thinking Anatoly look at what
anatoly karpov has done in this moment
in time
he's only moved his two bishops and his
King his rooks are rich on their
original squares and both of his Knights
are on their original squares okay and
on my side of the table what's very
interesting is I played efore d4f for
c-4 develop both my Knights develop both
my bishops my my rooks are about to come
into the game I played e4 okay then he
would play that not that Bishop takes c3
Bishop takes the three Knight f6
variation and the square e four wouldn't
be occupied one of our guiding
principles one of our guiding principles
is that when when we have an advantage
in development our goal is to open the
position no open the position trade
pawns open the position open up lines of
attack when we have the better mobilized
army it only stands to reason that we
need to open the position so we can take
advantage of the fact that we have
better development if we don't do this
our opponent is eventually going to
catch up in development and whatever
advantage we may have had just fades
away into the ether just no longer
exists so after E for let's see what
black could do if black takes with the
bishop oh I would have loved that one he
did not of course Anatoly didn't take
because that would have allowed me to
castle with a check and then for example
if he puts us King on c8 well notice
this diagonal on h3
I'd capture and win a bishop and let's
say he would have put his King on c7
well then once again I would capture and
then capture here winning decisive
material so in this position after E for
he definitely could not capture my pawn
with his bishop he played pawn takes I
can't whoops cat I cancelled
he took my knight because otherwise I
would capture his Bishop on d5 and here
he took my knight I took his pawn he
went here I took his rook he went here
well exactly he he felt it necessary to
sacrifice the exchange for upon and for
a knight
true enough
true enough okay so he and I went on
from here to win the game so the
question that the gentleman had asked me
earlier was I said really
from this position after c7 c6 it was
like how would I numerically assess the
how would I evaluate the position and on
the surface it looks like okay you could
give white a smidgen of an advantage I
mean you couldn't just say gosh black is
lost and yet I did after f4 Anatoli
makes I know but Anatoly makes what are
logical looking moves right Bishop e6 I
played Knight f3 Bishop h3 we understand
the logic of the moves that Anatoly
played and yet he ended up in a position
that was lost for him just lost yeah
okay so
sorry he did he went Bishop here that
was one he went Bishop here that was -
he went Bishop here that was three but
on the other hand on those tempies that
he did use well he was trying to shelter
his king so if we say that Bishop e6 is
a bad move because of led to this losing
position well what other moves can black
really make here from White's
perspective that's me I really would
like him to capture this would have been
made things much much easier for me okay
fair enough
let's let's let's analyze a move light
knight to D okay perhaps after the move
Bishop e6 okay so this was Bishop e6
Knight f3
he played bishop takes huh let's have a
look at the move Knight d7 okay so the
first thing that we have to look at is
Knight g5 so my plan with white is I
want to take this Bishop with check I
want to follow it up with Bishop to h3
attacking this pawn I would really hope
to pull your king to the e7 square so
that in the future I could play Bishop
e3 yes sir
okay okay okay so so in other words in
this position when I played f4 you mean
perhaps Anatole should play immediately
King csepp okay let's have a quick
look-see
so imagine King to c7 and imagine I
played the move Knight to f3 again I
really want you to capture my pawn so
that I can recapture with Czech gaining
time yes
let's say 97 okay so now I've got to
think because you're really making it
very attractive to me to play Knight g5
I'm wondering if I can exploit that or
not I'm not sure if I can or if I can't
that's a tough one
okay so I'll just go with the old
standby routine
I'll go Bishop h3 well in the first
place what I really want to do is
capture a fun I just love being pawns
ahead that's my favorite living
condition so just it's just that black
is a move or two away the the the the
development is not fitting for black and
it's only the difference of a tempo or
two between a completely acceptable
endgame or at least an endgame that I
find completely acceptable as black and
just the inclusions of Meuse g3 and g6
suddenly puts black on the edge quite
remarkable isn't it and like they like
such such subtleties can be the
difference at the highest levels after
I've won this game I handed up with
winning the tournament and Anatoly and I
were going
to the closing ceremonies so I'm talking
to him and I said Anatoly can I borrow a
speech excuse me I beg your pardon
so well you've won so many tournament
victories you probably have templates of
various speeches you made for various
audiences so could you please give me
one of the templates that you use when
you make a victory speech and we had a
good laugh over that I think at the time
then you may have to help me out here
Anatoly had won like a hundred and
twenty international competitions or
about that number does that seem like
about the right number tournaments all
over the world that he had won so this
was just an ending that I had wanted to
show and how when you're black even if
you're getting into an ending that's
kind of reasonable you have to be very
very careful about the moves that are
being included and it's just this very
strange the inclusion of this very
strange g3 and g6 that made all the
difference in the world again I just
wanted to put this ending up here for a
moment so this ending ePHI oops cancel
'if I've d4
a new variation d6 this ending I find
completely acceptable for black without
the moves g3 and g6
well exactly that's what what what Ben
had just said a moment ago that in this
position today amongst today's top
grandmasters they very often don't take
pawns and they don't trade queens
because they feel as do I that blacks
and games prospects
are not worse any question the final
position I don't have it on I don't have
it on this I have it on my computer the
game against Karpov it's all in the
databases I in fact that game has been
annotated quite heavily by yours truly
and and it's also in the book chess
tools not that I'm trying to plug my own
bug would I ever but I wrote a book
about all the games I played with the
world champions including Anatoly Walter
brown Walter brown I know
exactly yeah he's really he was yes yes
and where Walter really really got me is
Walter would obsess over his moves and
more often than that not he would get
into really really bad time trouble and
whenever Walter was in time trouble it
was he was like he was more dangerous
because I would literally have more time
but I fell in the trap
quite often of blitzing like with him
like I would try to I would try I would
speed
my tempo and the next thing you know he
was playing just super good and I think
in the first seven games more or less
like that I had two draws and like five
losses and the losses were just great
like every single game should go into
his best games collection and then
finally I broke the jinx and thereafter
I think we played a little bit well even
in my favor a bit but boy black Walter
brown was just the dark the black my
black opponent you know we all take our
customers for granted yeah you know like
Oh like all our cuz it but when you're
when you're somebody's customer uh uh
you know it was there yeah Walter did
not I see I see
any other questions yes sir there she's
English opening c4 yeah okay
okay you mean you had no idea what to do
when you were white
okay well this move c2 c4 it's called
the English opening whenever you're
white white because he has the first
move
he opens the game black because he
responds is often the defender so this
move is the English opening and then you
could have for example symmetrical
English if black were to play C seven C
five this is called the symmetrical
English and no variation you could have
a defense let's say Knight f6 yes so
let's say Knight f6 we would have for
example Knight f6 Knight c3 g6 we very
quickly might go into what is called the
Kings Indian defense well I started
playing the English opening as white a
lot when I was very young probably older
than you by the way I didn't start to
play chess until I was 12 but I played
the English opening with a very very
clear idea of when I was white let's say
mine yeah
[Music]
well that would be premature what I like
to do when I was white is I would just I
just show you let's say I'm just trying
to show some moves for for black for a
moment what I'd like to do when I was
white and in English is I like to
fianchetto my bishop I'd like to put my
bishop on the long diagonal so let's
just give some moves for black for a
moment and this is one of my one of my
favorite setups would be let's say like
this I would put my pawn my pawn on
c4d three my knight on c3 I would
fianchetto my bishop and let's give my
opponent some moves for just a moment
and I just love this concept somebody
very some very nice person I might add
said to me
yessir you're gonna lose a lot of games
but why don't you learn to build a
fortress
build a fortress oh that sounded so cool
yeah baby I'm gonna learn to build a
fortress yeah what is it how do I do
that so what I did what was explained to
me is when the bishop comes here to this
square G - this was called a fianchetto
it's an Italian world I still don't know
what it means by the way other than it's
called a fee and Cato fianchetto and I
put my knight here and I put my king
behind this nice little shield of pawns
my look is protecting my king my bishop
is guarding my king my knight is
guarding my king and this was called
building a fortress so it became my
favorite formation and I'd lose hundreds
of games but I didn't get checkmated in
two or three moves either so they would
beat me later and that was fine but in
the first part you know building a
fortress that became one of my favorite
strategies so you might try it yourself
may end up losing a lot of games but you
got to learn and like I said it sure
beat getting made it in for a 12 moves
whatever very very hard to lose fast
when you built yourself a fortress and
I'd rather win - well thank you all for
coming until next week
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]